Her low freak bitches though.
It's hilarious.
Everybody is on steroids.
What a great picture.
So hilarious. They might be
right. Yeah, they might be right.
You know what I started
watching last night,
I don't know if you'd say it [inaudible]
or [inaudible] is on Netflix.
It's all about doping and this uh,
this guy who was helping the
Russian team on Russians,
there was one estimate that it was
somewhere in the high nineties of Russian
athletes are on performance
enhancing drugs. That makes sense.
That's my thing with this whole Jon
Jones stuff and like I go back and forth,
I'm going to quote our friend
Eddie Bravo when you look into it,
when you look into it that try Nepal,
like so many guys article came out today,
I think I'm Fox Fox sports are came out
today of this guy who was a minor league
baseball player and he's a pro now and
he's tested twice for a positive and a
third time and he's waiting to see if
he gets banned for life because three
strikes,
you're out in baseball fan for life
and they're saying the how many guys in
baseball test hot for this Toronto Ball?
And they say in Gnc they have 47
products at GNC that this can show up us.
Wow. I know. So I saw that. My
God, fuck yeah, but wait a minute,
he's not supposed to be taking anything.
You're talking about a guy who was
already lost his ability to make a living
from Mexican Dick Pills.
Like why would he ever just take something
off the shelf at Gnc? Well, we're,
we're not giving the Guy Kudos because
he's the smartest tool in the shed. Short,
sharp, what I say, smartest tool in
the shed. Well, tools are smart too.
I smoked a little weed.
You don't have to say, he might've
been like, oh, I need energy.
Get me this.
What is that
bolt out of his neck?
And he takes that dude.
The truth is I would never do steroids.
I put that on my children.
I put that on my heavenly father.
He did not bring heavenly father,
loved how he capitalized
heavenly and father cause uh,
for sure do spect while re you know,
and get to hell has Spec Hispanic, um,
thirties facing up man.
Imagine if he comes back at
34 and still fucks everybody.
But he's 260 pounds at heavyweight just
merged. Fuck all this cutting weight.
Just just go on a power lift and
rampage for the next four years.
Keep your body in shape. It's still
fuck everybody up at heavyweight.
But if you look at that trend of ball man,
and you see how much,
how many guys test hot for it. And they're
like, what? Dumb fuck, it's not in there.
I can see Jones argument a
little bit. Yeah, I know.
I go back and forth and
I'm off the Jones Stream,
but when I see that and I see how big
of an issue it is in baseball and minor
league baseball, you Sada in the
commission might be like, fuck,
look at all these guys, man,
we've got real issue here.
Maybe he did fucked up so then I think
there's no way they give them four years,
but I asked,
they're going to realize I haven't heard
of anybody else tested positive for the
stuff in the UFC of you.
Is it the same stuff,
Frank Mir test positive for you?
This is other thing.
Usually if a guy tests hot for something
out of one of those major camps,
other guys can test hot for the same
stuff and last he's getting it straight
from the power lifter guys. Yeah, hours.
NFL brothers didn't
Frank Mir eat kangaroo.
Those is like tainted kangaroo meat.
Bro was at the worst argument efforts.
The worst ever because people don't
even eat kangaroos. Smart Guy.
He's the smartest tool in the shed.
Some people eat kangaroo,
but it's not common table
fair in Australia. Fuck No.
I was just in Australia doing shows them
how to eat kangaroo burger. No, fuck no.
They eat venison. Beef eating cake. Yeah,
but couldn't say what he was flagged
for. My favorite part, however,
he was still given a maximum
punishment by, you saw the,
I think as he claims he listed numerous
potential sources for the positive test
including eating kangaroo
meat while in Australia.
You saw it as like what out of here?
That's the best you got.
We've heard a bunch of shit,
but that's all you got, boy.
You know what's interesting? It's
like how much does it help? How much?
Like what? Think about like
what these guys are doing.
I mean definitely steroids help right
to steroids make you a better athlete.
They allow you to recover,
let's say 10% better. Yeah.
It's hard to tell though because could
John beat Daniel Cormay without that
small dosage of Terenna
Ball? Yes, he could do.
That's what DC was saying. He was
like, the guy doesn't need to do it.
He's super talented.
Does it need to do it?
I know that's why when you look at the
evidence and like why this small amount
of travel ball and you see all the
other guys testing pause for it,
how much would this really helped him
when he risked all this to take something
piss hot and it's really not helping
that much. And then where do we stop?
So right now we want to enlist and I've
been the fucking poster boy of making
fun of John on this stuff.
But in all seriousness, we're
do. We'd say, all right,
most guys are doing it.
Cause that there was this a heard Luke
Thomas talking about it. Uh, they uh, uh,
water right? Will sat in water. Yeah,
water is the big one. I think. Uh,
in 2007,
they did this survey of athletes including
fires that were going overseas and
competing and they,
they ask them as at a kind of under
the radar how many guys are doing
performance enhancing drugs. It
was an alarming number. Like 78%.
And that's people, you know. I bet it
would be a little higher than that. Yeah.
So like, you know what
I'm saying? So we're,
we're going to tarnish John's name
and he's not the greatest of all time,
but it's like, okay, but then
you'll pay to watch over him fight.
You'll pay to watch Vitor Belfort fight.
You know,
like we don't know exactly
who's doing what. Right.
But if Overeem becomes a champ, I
guarantee you if he pisses hot as a champ,
people turned on him too.
No, I get it. But he, he's,
he's tested for way worse things
than John has, but he hasn't, he,
we tested testosterone, right,
didn't he? It was just testosterone.
Oh my God, I got an elevated testosterone
levels pain. I mean the same shit.
Remember when he was Uber Rheem? That's
more than just tossed around. But he,
but he tested positive for that, didn't
he? And he said a doctor gave him a shot.
Wasn't that like the whole deal
at some doctor or shoulder at for,
I know there's no, I don't, but let's
just think about what they are like.
So he tested positive for
testosterone, I believe. Well,
if you test positive for that,
and if you had an exemption,
that means his levels were on that feet
doorbell coordinate mark cart shit where
they test, you're like, holy fuck man.
[inaudible].